[Music]
so let's just say you have your company
have your ID you have the industry you
know exactly how you're gonna tell your
story about your company and how you
gonna differentiate yourself against
everybody else in the marketplace so the
next question becomes how do you put the
right team together
if you have a problem if no one else can
help and if you can find maybe you can
hire who do you hire what kind of a
culture do you have that stain sustains
it how do you keep talent how do you get
the best talent how do you do all this
other stuff with your company there's
two challenges that everybody faces when
it comes down to putting the best team
together so it doesn't keep you up at
night by the way the best operators like
Bezos Gates Jobs
musk suck all these guys eventually
learn how to do this and if you do this
right it'll minimize headaches if you
don't do this right it's going to drive
you insane for a very long time so I'm
gonna cover two things that can help you
out with these challenges that we're
talking about so having said that as I
go through the video you got any
questions thoughts comments comment on
the bottom and if you haven't yet
subscribed to the channel click on the
sub button and join the notification
squad where your one the first I guess
two videos so let me get right into it
number one the first challenge is human
human capital what type of people you're
hiring because if you don't have this
hiring process right
you're definitely firing a lot of people
you're constantly upset with the people
you hire so humans on one side the other
one is organizational structure and
organizational structure has to do with
leadership develop and it has to do with
what kind of a leader you are it has to
do with expectations of everybody's work
what they're doing let's address the
human side first so if I was to ask you
right now what personality employee or
salesperson would do very well for you
with your company or your product on
what you're selling who would it be can
you answer that because that's the first
challenge you face in your hiring
process what personality do you want do
you need somebody that's bubbly do you
need somebody that's very serious
because you're in a regulated business
like hedge funds and compliance is
critical is that something you're
looking for do you need somebody that's
extremely curious what is extremely
creative what is it but you do need to
no the personality type the second thing
you need to know about the human capital
is their motivations and interest why is
that so critical I hired somebody that I
had no idea this person was looking for
a job only for three months cuz they
were going back to their country and we
talked to them but we never brought up
it was my fault that just kind of looked
at this person we started working three
months later I got to go back to my
country I got to go back like what are
you talking about yeah this was just a
job you never told me this well you
never asked whose fault is that my fault
not that person's fault I had another
person that I hired and their motivation
and interest was so simple it had
nothing to do with what I was doing and
what we were building that just wasn't
going to work because there was not that
drive to want to grow it in his position
required a lot of Drive that's again my
fault number three when it comes down to
human capitals your values and belief
system if your values and belief system
doesn't match with the person you're
hiring that's just gonna be a fight
eventually it's not gonna mesh you're
gonna have to fire another person or
someone's going to resign from you and
leave to another place number four
demographics demographics this age you
know ethnicity language they speak some
places women work better than men some
places men work better than women it's
just you need to know exactly what
you're looking for by the way that's the
human side right the human capital side
the other side is the structural
organizational part which is quite
frankly boring but I hate to say to you
this is exactly what makes you a lot of
money as boring as it is this is what
helps the business get thicker and
thicker and thicker and thicker and
thicker you're gonna make your high
equity high up you know dollars of
increasing your value in this area if
you do this right this increases the
value of the company to a whole
different level in this area so number
one when it comes down to structural
organizational structure number one is
their incentives their comp plans and
the rewards you give to them if that
parts not clear why are they working
harder than you wanted why are you so
upset if they're leaving that five
o'clock or six o'clock there's not an
incentive there's not a motivation what
is the purpose of it and I'm
specifically talking to you know sales
side and I'm talking to areas where he
can measure this out a guy that came in
and he started working with us
and I really like this guy and I sat
there with him we were moving back and
forth and he was telling me you know I
got the Scout one introduce you to so he
brings this guy he's from Croatia and he
says Pat I really need your help I said
what is it he's a CEO who runs a
business there and he says you know I'm
trying to get my sales guys going but
how do you motivate your salespeople I
said what do you mean I said hi my
salespeople are so unmotivated I'm just
so sick and tired of my so tell me your
compliment you pay them
he said twenty-five hundred dollars a
month I said what else go to keep
writing he says no no twenty-five
hundred dollars a month
I said so what do you mean he says
twenty-five hundred dollars a month
that's very high in Croatia I said you
need to tell me you got sales people
were the only thing you paid them is
$2,500 a month whether they make a
thousand sales or one sale yes who
competes against you he said nobody I
said what's my incentive to stay up to
ten o'clock at night none I said so
you're just trying to dictate what I
need to do no matter what I don't make
in twenty five he says I said your
awards your rewards your incentive your
comp plan sucks
we sat them we went through a few
different things we wrote a few
different things then he went back he
cost me back Pat were in three different
countries now were blown up he's so
exciting to me snaps all the time
because his business finally had the
right structure finally had to write
comp plans that produced the right
results he was looking for number two
number two number two is structure and
controls and what this mean structure
and controls is you know what is my
expectation
I work as a VP of such-and-such
department what do you expect from me
what is my day-to-day what do I need to
be doing
Who am I reporting to who reports to me
one of the managers here who reports to
them what do I tell them to tell them
what is your expectations of me it needs
to be very specific on your structures
and controls as my responsibilities that
I have in place number three is the
values and principles you have at your
office let me explain to what I mean by
this
some places you work they want you to
just focus on your one job and that's it
the value that you have at your offices
you come here from the morning you get
your job done and you go home right you
do that they're happy but another place
you work the value in principles is look
you got to be a team player you weren't
helping Larry Larry needed help today
and he asked you for you said no so
imagine if I'm going to place we're to
strap
the organizational setup that you expect
me to do my job and I'm trying to help
somebody else out or you explain to be a
team player but I'm all these things you
know to my job I'm gonna be
disappointing somebody which is you so
the more clear that is to the entire
environment everybody knows at this
workplace people like it that I work as
a team at this company people like it if
I just do my deal
everyone knows it's clear and last but
not least it's situational pressures let
me explain to what I mean by situational
price pressures when you run a company
crisis happens and all types of crisis
by the way just in the last seven days
three people have died in the company
and by the way three people that have
died are somebodies person that died
that's close here at the home office
one was a friend of mine one was one of
our executives here and then another one
was one of our VPS here three in the
same week this is situational how do we
handle it one was somebody's brother
says Pat I said look here's what you got
to do you only have one brother go
attend to him
meanwhile just please be accessible when
we need you because there's payroll and
we need to do in these two places but
Gautam you sure about that go attend to
him you have one brother go attend
that's the situational another thing we
had that took place when somebody had a
thing going on you know in some
companies I would say let's not address
it right now we'll get to three weeks
from now I looked at it and say I want
to address it today because I'm about to
go to India tomorrow and I go to Mumbai
I'm not gonna have a time for four or
five days I want to address it today we
flew my last nine midnight I had
breakfast with them today at 7 o'clock
for three hours we flown back out why it
was situational that needs to be
addressed today our culture is we
address it right off the bat why because
I don't want this to spiral into
something bigger but it's ours it
doesn't have to be yours regardless of
where you're at the other structural
part that you have in your company the
organizational structure that you have
that the leadership puts together which
is you that dictates in our company how
we handle different issues that will
come up that we have to handle these
pressures the sooner you have that
everyone's expectations clear so let me
go back to it again you have the human
capital side you need to get clear on
you have the organizational factors side
that you need to get clear on for on
both sides the sooner you're clear on
those four things the sooner you know
how to proceed
this to everybody and then your team's
gonna say oh shoot I don't fit this
culture six months later they filter
themselves out or you ask them to leave
and also this person fits the culture
perfect they stay there with you for 10
20 years oh my gosh I know this person
that would be perfect for this culture
and then your recruiting process yeah I
said with a person via that I'm hiring
them I want your think about this super
talented super genius super smart
everything was absolute genius at the
highest level I liked them
we liked each other we hit it off we
laughed everything was good not a fit at
all why was it not a fit he specifically
said what he doesn't want to do which
was the job description of what we
needed somebody to do by the way this
isn't his fault this is an art fault
it's not a fit both of us are mature
enough to say this will not be a fit
here I wish you all the best thank you
so much but if there's any other way I
can help you out let's come back to get
on work together excellent maturity
maturity but maturity on both sides now
imagine if we did whatever we could to
make this work and it's not going to
imagine if he said whatever we can do to
make it work but he doesn't travel and
we find out three months a year trap
that's a firing position it's ugly
reputation all these other things wasted
time wasted time wasted resources not
necessary maturity maturity great we
move on there sooner you have that the
easier it is going to be for you to hire
people and retain people and long in
that long term wise you grow your
business into a whole different level
because this is the one area you can
read all the books in a world you're
gonna get paid for this side you're
really gonna make your value on your
company for this side on how you put
your team together how you retain talent
with the company so now I have a
document PDF go to the bottom and go to
a website go download the document a PDF
and fill in all the four for both sides
for human and for your for your
organizational factors that you have
answer it get clear
implement it and go from there so with
that being said if you got any questions
thoughts comments comment on the bottom
and if you have not yet subscribed to
value teaming channel click on the sub
button and click on the alert so you're
one of the first that gets the videos
thank you everybody take care bye bye